We have some potentially dangerous animals performing here in Milwaukee this weekend.
The Shrine Circus is in town and 12 News Shelby Croft talked...
...with the show's producer about keeping the trainers and the audience safe.
It takes about six hours, five to six hours to do it all.
Elephant pedicures. It's part of the job for trainer Larry Carden. For anyone else, it's a daunting task.
Bow, our big elephant, is 13,000 pounds.
They are gentle giants...
...but circus producer Bill Cunningham explains that they still take great care in working with them.
Just like raising a child or managing a household, routine and consistency is very important.
Same goes for the tigers a few feet away.
While they look cuddly and lovable, it's always kept in mind they are ferocious animals by nature.
They're never left alone even for one second.
The circus has to follow strict rules and regulations when it comes to the animals.
Even the weight of the wires on the tiger cage is monitored.
They are not only subject to federal oversight but local, so we had the USDA in here this morning.
The animals have to be checked frequently by veterinarians.
Their health and state of mind are always taken into consideration.
If an animal isn't fit to perform, they're gonna get the proper care...
...and they're gonna get a day off, you know, just like anybody else.
Bill says an animal's temperament is looked at closely.
New animals are brought in with extreme caution and broken in slowly.
And first of all, the animals need to be comfortable with each other before they're comfortable performing.
This circus has never had a problem.
But anytime a person is working with wild animals, there's going to be a fear factor.
Part of the thrill of the circus is the danger aspect.
In Milwaukee, Shelby Croft, WISN 12 News.